[Música]
eu fotografo o universo
eu uso câmeras e lentes para fazer fotos
de nebulosas galáxias fenômenos
astronômicos da lua cometas
é incrível poder interagir com o cosmos
com equipamento portátil como esse que
eu uso no telão pessoal vocês vão ver
imagens que eu fiz ao longo dos últimos
dois anos em locais sem poluição
luminosa no brasil no chile e nos
estados unidos
no brasil o pessoal 80 por cento das
pessoas vivem dentro de grandes cidades
no mundo dois terços da população vivem
em locais onde não é possível enxergar
as estruturas da via láctea olho nu
somos cinco bilhões de pessoas no mundo
que não conseguimos interagir com essa
parte magnífica do cosmos dentro de uma
grande cidade
essa poluição luminosa posição do
horizonte com arranha-céus e prédios
impedem que temos uma noção real do que
está por trás dessa rotina frenética dos
grandes centros urbanos
nós os moradores de grandes cidades
simplesmente nos esquecemos do céu
noturno
essa minha actividade fotografar o céu
tem dois aspectos que eu sou apaixonado
que eu adoro
o primeiro deles é o seguinte há duas
semanas atrás eu estava na região centro
oeste do brasil fazendo minhas imagens
em dado momento da noite o vento
simplesmente parou e cria uma atmosfera
intimista muito interessante eu estava
com 360 graus em volta de mim abertos
parecia culpa de um planetário real
espetacular eu estou um pouco acostumada
com o céu noturno e vê muito estrela mas
é sempre incrível sempre me sinto em
casa quando a gente tem um ambiente
desse tipo pessoal é livre de poluição
luminosa com quantidade incontável de
estrela algo dentro de nós revive é
impressionante é como se fosse uma
libertação desse duro condicionamento da
vida das grandes cidades nós somos
transportados
o estado psicológico de tranquilidade e
de conexão com a natureza
segundo aspecto que eu acho incrível a
fotografia em si o que ocorre
nossos olhos têm uma alimentação
biológica principalmente em situações de
pouca luz
a câmera consegue além ela consegue
enxergar entre aspas além
por exemplo eu sei que tem uma nebulosa
na região do céu aqui meus olhos não
conseguem enxergar essas nuances de
cores e brilho a câmera consegue
enxergar
eu consigo muitas vezes é uma galáxia
difusão em algum ponto do céu reconheço
a olho nu mas a câmera consegue pegar um
ano antes de contraste de cor e brilho
que meus olhos não conseguem ver
é impressionante é uma atividade que eu
acho fantástica e é muito bacana e se
descortinar que a câmera permite vamos
buscar então por duas ações práticas
para que a gente possa interagir com o
céu noturno dentro de grandes cidades
a primeira delas é a seguinte existem
diversos clubes de astronomia dentro das
grandes cidades do brasil
aquino aqui no rio de janeiro existe um
aqui em são paulo também em outras
cidades espalhadas no brasil esses
clubes promovem com freqüência encontros
em praça pública ou em ruas onde
disponibilizam telescópios que você
consegue chegar lá e colocar seu olho na
ocular do telescópio enxergar por
exemplo as luas de júpiter os anéis o
anel de saturno é muito bacana eu já vi
os anéis de saturno de dentro do rio de
janeiro
eu já vi pessoal pessoas chorando
vendo os anéis de saturno e as luas
galileanas de júpiter pela primeira vez
a segunda parte que a gente pode
interagir como é que a gente cria um
outro formato para estar em contato com
o céu como é que a gente pode aprender
mais sobre astronomia bom sua próxima
viagem em família pode ser um local
livre de poluição luminosa com menos
poluição luminosa um sítio uma pousada
existem hoje diversas aplicativos de
celular que simulam o céu noturno em
qualquer local e horário que você tiver
no mundo então é muito interessante você
poder ter um local no sítio na pousada
comissão
e poder passar o celular assim ó pelo
céu e vai você vai recebendo informações
do que está no céu naquele momento muito
legal eu faço esse tipo de imagem
pessoal há três anos agora e enquanto eu
pensava o que é passar para vocês aqui
hoje uma frase em busca de muito
sentimento me veio que é a seguinte
interagir com o universo faz com que eu
me sinta o ser humano mais completo meu
lado pessoal se desenvolveu muito nesse
período de internação com as minhas
viagens com a minha fotografia e eu
percebi claramente uma expansão da noção
do que é a natureza do que é o universo
e principalmente do que é o kiko ou
carros que o meu pedido para nossas
crianças por exemplo
a interação com o céu noturno e com a
astronomia pode proporcionar uma chave
motivacional para impulsionar realmente
aprendizado sem que a gente tem que
necessariamente cobrar delas estuda faz
isso faz aquilo não é um desperdício
muito grande não usarmos astronomia na
nas escolas né astronomia e educação
elas formam o par perfeito astronomia
pessoal
ela é a mãe carismática de todas as
ciências para nós adultos o que pode ser
importante esse contato com a natureza o
universo pode servir como uma saudade ou
válvula de escape para esse frenesi
estressantes que são os centros urbanos
então o pessoal meu convite é o seguinte
é para que você interaja com o inverso
vá para uma noite para um local mais
afastado e quando você tivesse um local
mais afastado quero que vocês façam o
seguinte eu quero que vocês apaguem
todas as luzes
eu quero que vocês olhem pra cima que
vocês virem bem fundo e que vocês
contemplem o espetáculo que passa por
cima das nossas cabeças todas as noites
e que cinco bilhões de pessoas não
conseguem ver
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]